- Hello, everyone.
So welcome to another
episode of Unlocking Lily.
It's always been my dream to be a speaker,
which led me to quit my day job
to work and mentor under Evan full time.
And all of you are coming
along for the ride with me.
In every episode, I take
on a different challenge
to really help me grow as a speaker.
In this video, I'm going
to be starting with my why,
because I learned from Simon Sinek,
it's important for you to know your why
before you know your how and what.
Hey, everyone,
so today I'm going to be
teaching a one word workshop
at the library.
I'm going to do something a
little bit different than usual.
Instead of telling people what I do,
I'm going to start with my why.
I'm really excited,
because it's something I
have never done before.
I'm going to go in, grab my husband,
and we're going to be on our way.
I'm going to take you all there, too.
(upbeat music)
Hello, husband.
- You!
- [Lily] Ready to go?
- Uh, where?
(upbeat music)
- We live really far away from Toronto,
and usually our rides span anywhere from
an hour to two and a
half hours to three hours
into the city,
so the husband and I like to
trade interesting information,
and today he has something
interesting to tell you all.
- So I did some pretty
intense research on Wikipedia,
and I checked out the history of Innisfil,
and it comes from the Irish term
for the mythical name for Ireland,
which was Inis Fail.
So yeah, that's probably Gaelic, too.
- The reason why the husband
did the research on Innisfil
because we live in Innisfil.
So to my Irish friends
out there, is that true?
Does Innisfil translate to Ireland?
Tell me.
Leave in the comments below.
I'm curious to find out.
(upbeat music)
Hey, everyone.
So I'm finally here at
the Toronto Library,
the Malvern division.
This workshop is extra special for me,
because I am from Malvern,
and to be back here feels great.
It kind of reminds me
of when I was a teenager
walking up and down these streets,
and before ... There's some music pumping.
That's what I remember about Malvern, too.
Before I go to any workshops
or any kind of encounter with people,
I always think about the
intention that I want to set.
What is the intention that I
want when people are leaving?
And the intention today is for them
to feel something that sparks inside them,
inspire them to go take action
and go out there and live
an extraordinary life.
So I'm really excited,
a little bit nervous,
but mostly excited.
And we're going to go inside,
and I'll catch you guys soon.
(bright music)
So I just had the workshop.
It was great.
I couldn't record much
of the people inside.
It's just a part of library laws.
But it was good.
It was really good.
It was different.
It wasn't the big group that I'm used to,
but it became like a one-on-one coaching,
which is what I love.
And I think a lot of people
are going to take action,
and hold themselves accountable,
and do something great.
A lot of great words came out of it, too,
which I'm really excited about.
Anyway, we're going to go and
spend some time with the family.
See you guys soon.
(bright music)
I just got back from doing
the workshop at the library.
When I was there, I had
so many great memories
coming back to me.
I remember when I was a 16-year-old girl
who had nothing, just big
dreams and a strong work ethic,
and how a lot of people
took a chance on me.
I had these great teachers,
these great guidance counselors,
who helped me form a path for myself
to be able to go out there
and achieve my dreams
and how they believed in me,
believed that I was
capable of doing a lot more
than I was doing at that time.
And when I was there, I realized that
I can be that for someone now.
Number one, I'm not that girl anymore.
I have a lot to give.
And number two, I could
do that for someone.
I can be the guide for someone.
I could help them pave their path.
I grew up in a really poor neighborhood
where a lot of people don't get out.
I was able to get out.
I could go back there and
do that for someone else,
and then hopefully they could
and it all just kind
of comes a full circle.
And that further solidifies my why.
My why is to inspire
people to be extraordinary
so they could inspire
others to do the same,
and then how we can all
do this together as one.
That's the reason why I make these videos.
That's the reason why
I want to go to speak.
That's the reason why I coach people.
Everything I do is because of that,
and being there really,
really confirmed it for me
even though I was
uncomfortable with it at first.
I didn't know how to say it.
But I'm glad I did,
because it showed me
and proved to me that,
that really is my why.
So the question of the day is,
what is your why?
Please write in the comments below,
and I'll join in on the discussion.
So my last episode, when
I talked about overcoming
my fear, I said that I wanted to speak
in front of a lot of people on stage.
So I think the next thing
I want to do is like
go on a big stage and speak
in front of a lot of people.
A lot.
Hundreds of people.
That's what I would like to do.
Yeah.
So surprise, I actually
have a TEDx Talk coming up
in Michigan, so for my next challenge,
I'm going to be bringing
all of you on the road trip.
I am so excited to bring you guys along
for my first TEDx talk.
I have a special shout-out
for Choria Graphic Arts.
Choria Graphic Arts wrote,
Choria Graphic Arts, first of all,
thank you so much for
sharing that with us.
I do want you to know
that you're not alone,
and it's okay to feel
discouraged from time to time,
but I want you to know that
we're all rooting for you.
So thank you so much for watching.
Every time an episode comes out,
I get so excited to read your comments.
And every time you share
something with me in the comments,
I feel like I know you a little bit better
and how we're all in this together.
Again, thank you so much,
and I will see you guys very, very soon.